yes well you heard the Home Secretary
there telling the House of Commons a
short time ago that it was what she
described as a multi-agency response but
that response had actually involved some
private fishing vessels and we have
heard now firsthand account of a skipper
of a fishing vessel by the name of
Raymond who's told Sky News that the
first he was one of the first on scene
and the first he knew of the fact that
there were people in distress was he
heard screaming around his boat it
actually woke him up he said and some of
the extraordinary footage he shared with
us shows him and his crew pulling some
30 to 40 migrants out of the water he
said that they were from all over the
world in fact he said Afghanistan Iraq
Senegal India and they all told them
that they'd paid 5 000 pounds to a
people Smuggler in France for passage to
the UK Raymond said that these people
were all given hot or well he described
them actually as lukewarm showers on his
fishing vessel and then brought him to
land where they were then uh looked over
by border Force officials and given
medical assistance but all of them he
said survived I think the most striking
thing though when you see that footage
you just played some of it if you want
to if you missed that watching at home
you can go and look at on the Sky News
website is the sheer unseaworthiness of
the vessel they are in it is it looks
like a paddling pool that is slowly
deflating in icy cold Waters as people
frantically try and Scrabble out of it
to safety and sadly that is the business
model that so many of these people
traffickers use they're putting people
clearly at risk we know fatally now with
four lives lost overnight in
spectacularly unseaworthy vessels and
it's left to people like Raymond the
Border force and others to pull them out